The joe rogan experience. I
love Oprah. Don't get me wrong.
I think she's a wonderful woman.
I think she's a powerful force of good
and positive energy, which ain't no Eli,
but she also brought us doctor Oz and
the secret we have to remember with this
lady has done, she has to be
held accountable. I forgive her,
but I mean cut the shit.
The secret is a particularly egregious
offense. What you don't, you just, Oh,
you don't believe,
don't believe who believe.
I want to be rich.
I just am rich.
I imagine myself flying.
I can fly.
I will beat my wings until
I take off what's up.
Yeah,
it was one of the more confused,
I want us to be disturbing,
but it was confusing when that
was taking hold with people.
When I had friends that were telling me
that the secret is real and that they
imagine they were going to fulfill
these childhood dreams that they had had
about whatever, being a fucking
astronaut, whatever, whatever it would be.
There's a couple people that I knew.
They were trying to tell me that the
secret was going to be the thing and that
they had a vision board
and they had photographs.
They put pictures up of the things that
they want to like them in front of large
crowds and shit. And I'm like,
Oh boy, this is large crowds.
It's just so not how it works.
Yeah.
But there is a kernel of it that works.
Yup.
Cause it was thinking you wanting
something, you envisioning it,
but that's a little component
and just how you live your life.
It's not just sitting in your,
you know what it's like and wishing it.
So it's like saying I am going to be
a bodybuilder because I drink water.
Yeah. It's like no, you okay. Geez.
Where do I start?
You,
you should drink water and it will help
you if you want to be a bodybuilder.
But I've talked to all these bodybuilders
and the one thing they have in common
is they all drank water and they
knew that if they drank water,
they would be giant. There'd
be giant, huge people. It's
all you've got to go. Okay.
But did they also perform reps to failure?
Did they also take steroids?
Did they also do these exercises?
Squats, dead lifts, curls, you know,
did they do all that stuff too? Yes,
but that but the water,
why aren't you a believer?
This is what it's like cause cause
they're saying like no, these people,
they believe that they can
do these things. They they,
they had this vision and they focus on
this vision and it came to fruition. Yeah.
You know what they also did?
They also busted their fucking ass and
got lucky and we're in a business or
career that they had some talent in
and figured out what that career is and
figured out how to navigate the very
weird waters of social interaction and
skill acquisition and success and failure
and learn from your failure and luck.
Yeah. That's the big problem is
you're dealing with complete. Yeah.
At sampling bias, you're, you're only
asking people that are in the mansions.
Tom Papa, how did you do
it? I mean I see you here.
You have this place. It's as big as
the White House. You have a giant lawn.
Did Judge Joe always know this
was going to be your reality.
I saw it and I just put
it on my vision board
and the obviously it doesn't stick around.
It'd be didn't it became a
fad because all these people,
well at some point that's
take the board down.
Fortunately some people died because they,
um,
there was a story I was reading about
Oprah unfortunately where this woman had
terminal cancer and she,
she had stage three breast cancer and
just decided that through the secret she
was going to imagine herself
a healthy person and you know,
she eventually want them dying from it
because she, she didn't get treatment.
The IAA,
I mean she,
she stopped that she stopped
conventional medical training.
But what part of,
so how far do you go
with positive thinking?
Cause I see you as a fella that,
uh,
has goals and I would think positive
thinking plays into your life.
What does that even mean? Really?
Like do I think pauses? I, I,
I think in a positive way.
I try to be positive.
I try, but when you're trying
to accomplish something,
whether you're trying to, you
know, get better at something,
like say if you're playing a game,
like what if you like golf,
like say take up golf and you
want to be a really good golfer.
Like you start thinking about golf,
like how do I get better at golf?
You have to learn, you have to pay
attention to a instructional videos.
You have to maybe seek out coaching,
you have to play some games and lose,
you have to choke under pressure.
You have to examine the mental game.
Like what is wrong with my mental
process when I approach a shot?
What is wrong with this? What
is wrong with it? And then
become obsessed with the,
the idea of succeeding in that.
And I think that that can
apply to everything. So yeah,
I mean I certainly believe
in positive thinking,
but that was like mystic nonsense.
No,
that tips over and it discounts all
the other stuff that you have to do
something to the law of attraction.
It is,
but it is one component to this gigantic
sort of spectrum of factors that have
to be taken into consideration when you're
trying to succeed at something. Yeah.
Positive thinking is one of them,
but it's also the understanding
of how to eliminate laziness,
how to discipline yourself, how
to write down goals, how to,
how to make incremental
steps towards improvement,
how to recognize failure is not
just the end of all your hard,
but in fact the beginning of
a new breakthrough because
you understand like how
to never do this wrong, wrong
the wrong way again. Yeah,
and the consequences
of doing things wrong.
It's like there's a lot of
a lot of factors in getting
better and succeeding at
things. Yeah, and it's, they
boiled it down to the easiest one,
which is dreaming. Right,
right. Exactly. Exactly. Just,
just that's why it's sold, but
oversold it. I mean, she was, yeah,
she was one of the big
ones, man. And she was in,
she was fucking 50 years old at the time.
I mean,
this is not a young woman who was
selling this. How old is open now?
75 89 no,
she just ran a marathon in
four hours. Did she? Really?
67 63 so she ran a marathon.
Yeah.
So let's,
let's think of when the secret came out.
I want to say that was like 2006 ish.
2004 2006 okay,
so 12 years ago she was,
so she was 50 years old.
How the fuck did you not know when you're
50 years old and worth $1 billion that
that's not how it works. But it's Hocus
pocus. Yeah. It's not hocus pocus. Yeah,
and to sell that to people is crazy.
And that's a book that's sold.
I think I was reading it's soul somewhere
in the neighborhood of 20 million
copies. Wow. Is that what it says?
Yeah. Jeez, that's crazy. Well,
you want an easy way. You want
something that's easy. Everybody wants,
you're in trouble, you're feeling
whatever and they want something to come.
Something come and help me.
I mean it's where religion comes from.
It's just please, there's that
thing inside of us is like, ah,
I want to believe if I believe, is that
enough? It is a lot like that. Yeah.
There was one of Trump's
spiritual advisors was, uh,
he's got some spiritual
advisors, some woman who was, uh,
telling people to send her money.
There was a set,
send her money for January. There was
some, so some whole article about it,
but it's basically essentially the
same thing. It's like the idea is that,
what is she saying?
Donald Trump's spiritual advisor.
Paula white suggest people send her
there January salary or face consequences
from God. No. Is that true?
She's attractive too. Is Interesting.
Is that true? Yeah. Look at our Pam,
I'll give you money. What do I gotta do?
All right. I'll you what I do, Paula,
how much do you need?
I don't know if that's a good picture.
Maybe she just looks cool when
she's screaming. Yeah, she
looks good. But, um, yeah,
I would love for some,
really,
I would love for the day where there's
some real powerful spiritual, uh,
individual who doesn't ask for money.
You will. That's fine. Who doesn't? Who?
Real power. Powerful or spiritual
individual. It's a huckster.
That's what I mean.
[inaudible].